estas imágenes de drones dan testimonio
de la magnitud de los daños justo en el
centro de Odessa
un edificio Residencial y una zona
comercial desfigurada por los ataques
rusos
aquí hay cristales reventados por las
explosiones y a unos metros todo un
almacén está en peligro de derrumbarse
[Música]
a las 2 de la madrugada en medio de la
noche escuché una explosión Vivo lejos
de aquí al lado de la fábrica de micrón
pero lo escuché Desde allí
miedo
escuché unas advirtiendo del peligro
pero ni
siquiera tiempo de ponernos a cubierto
cuando sonó la explosión luego nos
escondimos en un estacionamiento
subterráneo
es aterrador esas personas no son
humanas
fue obra de un misil de crucero ruso
cabrir según autoridades ucranianas que
afirman haber interceptado otros tres en
total
el enemigo atacó la región de odesa con
misiles lanzados desde el mar Negro se
dispararon cuatro misiles en el centro
de Odessa
debido al combate aéreo una fuerte
explosión dañó varios edificios un
almacén comercial tiendas allí en ese
edificio hubo varios heridos
la ciudad portuaria de Odessa favorecida
por ucranianos y rusos para sus
vacaciones ha sido bombardeada muchas
veces desde el comienzo de la invasión
rusa a gran escala en los últimos días
el ejército de Vladimir Putin ha
intensificado los ataques en varias
regiones incluyendo en el este donde
otras tres personas fallecieron una
campaña de bombardeos masivos mientras
las fuerzas ucranianas llevan a cabo su
contraofensiva en múltiples frentes con
algunos éxitos militares quien reclama
la reconquista de varias localidades
ocupadas por los rusos